piden responsabilidades al fbi y a los
organismos deportivos oficiales de eeuu
cuatro gimnastas olímpicas entre ellas
la campeona olímpica si mobiles
denunciaron la inacción sistemática ante
las denuncias de abuso sexual cometidos
por el médico olímpico la renacer
para ser claros culpo al jardín nazarí
también culpó a todo el sistema que
permitió y perpetró soluciones
usa gimnástic si el comité olímpico y
paralímpico de eeuu sabían que fui
abusada por el médico oficial del equipo
mucho antes de que yo me diera cuenta de
su conocimiento también comparecieron la
ex gimnasta mayné nicholls primera en
denunciar a nasser y las atletas mckayla
maroney y aller brace manent culparon al
fbi de no haber atendido a tiempo las
quejas presentadas desde 2015
nasser abuso de más de 330 jóvenes y
ahora cumple una condena de entre 40 y
175 años por ello y otra de 60 años por
pornografía infantil
los testimonios llevaron al director del
fbi a pedir perdón
en
zúrich me siento profundamente apenado
con todas y cada una de ustedes lamento
por lo que ustedes y sus familias han
tenido que pasar sobre that's so many de
frontín siento mucho que tantas personas
las hayan decepcionado una y otra vez y
lamentó especialmente que hubo personas
en el fbi que tuvieron su respectiva
oportunidad de detener a este monstruo
en 2015 y fallaron
es inexcusable nunca debió ocurrir y
estamos haciendo todo lo que está en
nuestro poder para que nunca vuelva a
pasar
al menos 40 niñas y jóvenes denunciaron
haber sido abusadas sexualmente por
nacer en los 14 meses que siguieron a la
primera denuncia presentada contra él
ante el fbi